okay ready let's do this we do an
interview report ha
you blink I can see everything no not
that I can see good
no I Catherine I can see everything
babalu apply labels I think so beards
before those Soviets the booty bah bah
bah kill them while they're young when I
say the new feeling good
I believe I did Baloo youngest Pharaoh
in Egyptian armies I will be busy busy
building a pop play in the group no the
guy named Moses oh it's me of Oliver
that movie dude
[Music]
hi I'm king of squirrels hi I'm king of
the squirrels hi I'm Caitlin rose
I know this looks weird
Dora magic Clark this is your ball this
is your ball on drugs any questions
[Music]
sorry did it go
they in the face
it was like I flex my wrist anyway
effective ticking I'm sorry
it can never work between us
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you suffering from chronic unfunny
syndrome when you have no ideas left to
put your stupid [ __ ] microwave use
good assume be stuck on my hands if you
are like me and you have nothing funny
left just go watch other youtubers and
steal from them and then you have a
whole truck full of fine stuff and
you'll never run out because everyone's
more creative than you anyway so why
even buy the time tonight effects may
include repressed nightmares planetary
already complex low self-esteem a
complete loss of bowel function you may
have explosive tail
oh well don't mind me that's fine
know what no please die die I'm sorry
you're done I know it's hard to accept
you can't run away sorry you're dying
[Music]
and you can successfully uh whistle oh
so I I stabbed him I stabbed him and I
stabbed him and I was laughing at him
laughing and I just died yeah I think
that that would be considered a sin
p-value god damn mind how many drugs are
you on right now oh [ __ ] God you know I
just feel like I'm a little misguided
here there seems to be all these
misunderstandings where people just end
up dying around me for various random
reasons maybe you need to pawn more am I
cursed father
maybe you're cursed where are you from
maybe your course where maybe these are
cursed
don't touch me where are you from what's
your accent
hello one or two people my name is
markiplier and back with another episode
of so not again tomorrow I'll be playing
happy wheels let's get into it
I died I really hope you haven't gotten
my cue because there's a [ __ ] nail
right there you got any my keyboard
there now oh [ __ ] I bet you have I don't
know
[ __ ] here we go bonhomie ma d ba ma ba
ba ba ba ba keep it up
it want to talk about your stick ah yeah
I just found this stick I think it's +22
bear slang it's pretty pretty
aerodynamic like if you get a good
witness to it I think it's sturdy as can
be it's a good bloodletting stick you
just and then the blood drains out so I
don't know it's got some heft to it it's
perfectly balanced as you can see it
it's that it's perfectly balanced 100%
authentic wood
yeah do you like that yeah like you like
that do it where to go here to my hand
the whole time well fool ain't always
coming back to you oh yeah watch this
right back to me yeah wait go to
Australia
oh good I might is back [ __ ]
I kinda hello I'm on my knees give me a
short dog ha
Tyler can you go get a Clorox wipe see i
mighta had a little dribble dribble on
the driver seat oh you know which one
only if you help just by clicking that
button down there you can make a
difference in one man with way too big
of an ego you can make his head to swell
a little bit larger and as hard will be
exactly the same in light of YouTube's
restrictive ad policy we will be
completely family-friendly from now on
words like [ __ ] and [ __ ] and [ __ ] will
be replaced with family-friendly
alternatives like fudge and shooters and
[ __ ]
do you want smaller youtubers like crank
gameplays jacksepticeye ojii-chan YT
growing out of nowhere and replacing the
wonderful marklar no I don't even know
who they are
get get out of here get out get get get
get [ __ ] oh if you don't help subscribe
to markiplier
he's going to have to shut down his
other channels that you may know as
shoenice keemstar ojii-chan whitey Kirby
gluey they're all him they're all me I
am everyone PewDiePie That's not me
the aliens have probed peacefully and
now for the weather
Jim and all of the Badgers thankfully
died and now for the weapon Jim and
Arnold Schwarzenegger's last words were
hasta LaVista
I cheated on my wife
now for the weather Jim and so that's
how rabies became the new weight-loss
sensation that swept the nation and now
for the weather
Jim and I I believe that the storm
should pass millions have died thus far
we're having a good time out here Jim
thanks Jim we're really in a scramble
out here it's currently raining cats and
dogs and I thanks Jim as you can see we
made it to what I can only assume is the
middle of the ocean I don't know how I
got here
Jim got a little bubbles bubbles all
glory to the hypnotoad and boom Simba me
know him Baba Sabu Sheba giving him the
bow ebon bum
[Music]
October chicken gigabyte to be Bahamas
ooh FIFA Napa it's the money fake he's
dumb anyone don't beat one he's gonna be
warm oh it's gotta be mine that's gonna
be my it's gonna blame my it's gonna be
May
yes gonna beim a it's gonna bring me
it's gonna be my that's gonna be my it's
gonna bring me that's the end I said any
closing thoughts I am I'm careless for